bienvenidos a enlace conosur en esta
emisión desde buenos aires argentina
nuestro tema de hoy las dificultades
actuales en la producción rural y en las
industrias que utilizan sus productos
como insumos argentinas es uno de los
más grandes productores agrícolas del
mundo también es un gran exportador de
soja girasol y trigo entre otros en el
contexto de la crisis que atraviesa el
país y con el transfondo de la guerra en
ucrania la producción la distribución y
el procesamiento se ven comprometidos y
ponen en tensión al campo y la ciudad
aunque argentina tiene una de las
superficies cultivables más grandes del
mundo en el país la gente vive
fundamentalmente en entornos urbanos el
más grande es este buenos aires- que
contando su conurbano aloja a
aproximadamente un tercio de la
población del país esto es algo que se
encuentra ya en el origen de la nación
como nos explica el historiador royce
ahora de hecho ya para comienzos del
siglo 20 la argentina era un país más
urbanizado que cualquier país europeo
con excepción de gran bretaña y los
países bajos y eso tiene varias razones
pero una muy importante es el hecho de
que no tuvo una historia campesina no es
cierto para decirlo rápido la historia
de pequeña propiedad campesina sino que
el campo argentino el campo exportado se
armó como una economía muy capitalista
desde muy temprano y que ahí se debe a
que es muy productivo es decir con con
muy poca gente viviendo allí se puede
sacar un montón de kilos de lana carne
trigo etcétera no es cierto y eso tiende
a favorecer la urbanización estas dos
argentinas la urbana y la rural se tocan
entre otros puntos en el procesamiento
de una parte de la producción primaria
una elaboración que muchas veces ocurre
en las ciudades como en esta fábrica de
fideos que se encuentra en las afueras
de la ciudad de buenos aires- al
visitarla se reveló la situación de
crisis que vive el país hoy estamos sin
fabricar puntualmente por falta de
harina no hemos recibido harina en
tiempo y forma porque no recibe harina
se han conjugado factores por un lado de
problemas con la distribución por falta
de combustible para camiones por otro
hay un parate generalizado por la crisis
interna de argentina llevado que algunos
productores también de materias primas
frenarán los envíos esperando a que se
aclare el panorama o que aumenten los
precios que ya subieron por la guerra en
ucrania la harina que utiliza fabián
meritxell y en su fábrica nacen campos
como este en forma de trigo también se
siembran aquí otros cultivos como maíz o
soja que son clave en la economía del
país pero se estima que en 2022 la
producción de trigo será menor que la de
2021 va a haber bastante menos trigo lo
que se podría lejos las 22 millones del
año pasado creo que no sé si vamos a ver
a las 20 millones
hay efectos climáticos y el impacto de
la guerra en ucrania por ejemplo en la
provisión de fertilizantes pero para
fernando de nevares también influyen
ciertas políticas públicas la
intervención ya sea vía retenciones o
con cupos de exportación no hacen más
que en embarrar la cancha generar
desconfianza en el corto plazo el
productor busca retener la mercadería
porque entiende que tiene expectativas
alcistas de esa producción y en el largo
plazo desalienta la inversión y la
siembra de cereal entonces tienen efecto
exactamente contrario de lo que yo
entiendo que con buena fe buscan pero no
no se generan muchos en argentina
consideran que las retenciones y los
cupos son una forma razonable de por un
lado mejorar la recaudación en un
momento de crisis y por el otro contener
los precios internos frente al
incremento de los valores en el mercado
internacional es por cierto lo que
piensan en el gobierno y que genera
persistentes tensiones con el sector
rural en la fábrica de fideos fabián
menichelli cree que es una buena opción
si me conviene digamos el hecho de que
las retenciones me atenúen el impacto
digamos salvaje de una devaluación
repentina
la mente sí sí que me conviene porque
sobre todo las pymes no tenemos la
capacidad de trasladar a precios de
ventas y ese aumento de la harina se lo
pasó a precio de ventas no es no es no
es así pero a la vez dice entender a los
productores de trigo que entre la
incertidumbre a la espera de mejores
precios de morán entregas ahora me
parece que cada así a mí me parece bien
porque el producto de señal va a buscar
maximizar su beneficio o sea en la
medida que no entendamos eso no está
cumpliendo su rol de empresario este
tipo de encrucijada de desacople entre
la producción primaria de exportación y
el consumo local no es algo nuevo y
genera dificultades para encausar la
economía del país cómo se puede resolver
más allá de las retenciones y los cupos
hacia dónde puede ir el país hay
expertos que piensan que argentina debe
volcarse a la incorporación de valor
agregado sobre las producciones del
campo y otras áreas biológicas yo
sostengo es que buena parte de los
problemas que tienen la argentina hoy
dependen de la estructura productiva y
esa estructura productiva
está armada sobre la base de una
industria que ya fue en general y que es
muy difícil volver a replicar a futuro
ese mundo fue reemplazado por la moderna
biotecnología y por la electrónica
aplicada a grandes procesos y argentinas
perdió ese tren entonces cuál es la
alternativa que le queda argentina
además de rescatar lo que quedó del
aparato industrial previo necesita otro
motor potente de desarrollo que
presumiblemente la podemos encontrar en
las producciones de origen biológico
industrializada en su totalidad lo que
llamaríamos el nuevo campo para quienes
creen en ese nuevo campo se trata de la
solución que dejaría atrás las tensiones
entre un sector rural de gran tamaño
para la economía y los espacios urbanos
donde vive la mayoría de los ciudadanos
pero para que funcione también
implicaría el crecimiento de centros
urbanos medianos cerca de las
producciones rurales y la migración
desde grandes conglomerados como buenos
aires- eso sería mucho más que un cambio
de matriz productiva sería una completa
transformación del país a ustedes
gracias por acompañarnos en esta edición
de enlace con azul los invito ahora a
seguir con la programación de france 24
[Música]